welcome back there's a huge rise in
Americans taking and faking sick days
perfectly healthy workers are lying to
their bosses over the real reason why
they're calling out some attribute it to
their frustrations or mental health
While others simply put it this way same
quote it was a gorgeous day I just
wasn't in the mood to work either way
there's a 45% increase in younger
workers using sick days Dana I feel like
you hate that stuff well I um if you
need uh if you're sick you shouldn't
come to work because nobody else wants
to get germs I just remember even from
when I was a little kid I hated to miss
school and if I if I was legit sick and
I had to stay home I was so nervous
about anything I was missing at school
not socially so much but from the
homework perspective I never wanted to
be behind and I still feel like that
today I don't like being away from work
I but I appreciate the time off when I
get it I would never take a fake sick
day I just wouldn't do it I love working
I love being here and I don't know what
I would do if I found out someone on my
team took a fake sick day I don't know
what I'd do I'd probably be like she
on them well I would be scared too that
someone would find out like no
repercussions Greg well I'll just have
to point out that in the Green Room Dana
asked me if she would be uh if there
were any availability to work on my
holiday shows and I'm not joking no way
but you know what I hate get some rest I
know you know what I hate people who use
their kids to get out of work because I
don't have that in my Arsenal so I have
to come up with other lies I might adopt
a kid just to get off Fridays right I've
been going you know I've been going to
Children's birthday parties stopping by
orphanages doing a little window
shopping listen if I'm here on Fridays
you better be here on Fridays Gutfeld
you know what I would do remember The
Office episode where Oscar called in
sick and Dwight went to his house to
conduct surveillance and it turns out he
wasn't sick he was just gay you remember
that he caught him with his gay lover
that's what I would do I would send
someone to the house to confirm oh my
God
judge so it's my turn after that yeah
all right the only thing I can tell you
is you're entitled of sick days the
question as to whether or not a mental
health day is a sick day to me the
answer is no and you know I've heard
people say you know what I'm going to be
sick Thursday and Friday on Tuesday that
infuriates me because when I ran office
nobody would dare do that you but we
this is post pandemic you know who you
can blame for this you can blame the the
pandemic and I was going to say fouchy
or China which one China China what if
you're sick in the head huh what if
you're sick in the head yeah then China
too for some reason but the truth is
that everybody's just getting lazier and
nobody wants to work and I can't stand
it and I'm like Dana you know but I'm
not interested in being working on a
holiday Greg so don't ask all I said was
if never mind one more thing I did I did
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else